el destacado periodista guatemalteco
José Rubén Zamora quien ha publicado más
de un centenar de artículos en los que
relaciona al actual presidente Alejandro
yamatei en presuntos casos de corrupción
podría enfrentar hasta 40 años de
prisión esto a razón de la solicitud que
hizo el Ministerio Público o la fiscalía
hoy en la audiencia de la fase final del
juicio en su contra en el tribunal
octavo de ciudad de Guatemala los 40
años de prisión estarían repartidos en
20 años y una multa de 38 mil dólares
por presunto lavado de dinero 12 años
por tráfico de influencias presunto
tráfico de influencias y ocho años por
supuesto chantaje y durante la solicitud
de estas penas por parte del Ministerio
Público a José Rubén Zamora se le vio
riendo de manera que a la salida del
tribunal explicó entre líneas lo absurdo
de su caso hizo referencia a la famosa
narcotraficante guatemalteca mayor y
Chacón conocida como La reina del sur
quien pagó cinco años de cárcel de dijo
que mantiene su patrimonio intacto por
haber lavado la suma cercana a los 5.000
millones de dólares mientras que en su
caso en el que se le acusa de haber
lavado 38.000 dólares Pues podría llegar
a pagar esta dura pena de 40 años no
cesan los las denuncias de organismos
locales e internacionales de que este es
un juicio plagado de todo tipo de
irregularidades donde ha tenido que
prescindir de nueve abogados y donde se
evidencia que el aparato judicial en
Guatemala va en contra de la libertad de
expresión Y responde a la solicitudes
del ejecutivo a sus 66 años Zamora ha
perdido 35 libras Durante los 10 meses
de prisión en que ha estado desde su
captura en julio pasado y está la espera
de la sentencia definitoria aunque se
ampara en poder llevar su caso a los
tribunales internacionales